are bacteria conscious well they're
really in control of your body in your
digestive tract they're more bacteria
that live and work within one centimeter
of your lower colon than the total
number of humans who have ever been born
so however high up you want to think of
yourself to the bacteria you are a
darkened vessel of anaerobic fecal
matter
gracitizen welcome to the show yeah
thanks thanks for having me thank you we
were discussing your overly Baroque
column background behind you before we
got started I've got a story about Sir
Christopher Wren famous English
architect during his extremely long
career as England's most celebrated
architecture so Christopher Wren was
often told by his patrons to make
impractical changes in his designs never
once did he argue or offend he had other
ways of proving his point in 1688 Ren
designed a magnificent town hall for the
City of Westminster the mayor however
was not satisfied in fact he was nervous
told Ren he was afraid the second floor
was not secure and it could all come
crashing down on his office on the first
floor he demanded that Ren had two stone
columns for extra support Ren the
consumer engineer knew that these
columns would deserve no purpose and
that the mayor's fears were baseless but
build them he did the May was grateful
it was only years later that Workman on
a scaffold saw that the columns stopped
just short of the ceiling they were
dummies both
both of them got what they wanted the
mayor got his columns and ren actually
didn't have to molest his uh original
design I think uh it wasn't one of the
big reasons he was catapulted to
significance was that he was an active
and celebrated architect at the time of
the London Fire I don't know but that
would have been around about the right
time 16 years yeah and I think so and
and you got to rebuild stuff right
afterwards and I I so I had some memory
that he he was around when when people
needed Architects so I asked a good
friend a historian about which British
person from history did he wish had more
exposure in the modern world and he said
dick Whittington
why do I know that name so dick
Whittington the real character that was
Dick Whittington ended up being this
rich guy it was cat stick Whittington
and his cat was the story that you might
have heard
um but he ended up giving away almost
all of his money the still buildings
that are alive today and educational
grants and all sorts of stuff that are
Downstream from this one guy and his
cats oh okay cool yeah I've heard the
name I didn't remember why I know the
name it's a British history for you
though you've got a quote that says it's
not good enough to be right you also
have to be effective what does that mean
yeah uh that comes to me from my father
among a couple of other sort of wise
epithets
that one
you know if you if you want to change
the world in some Progressive
positive way
then you can go out and just scream at
people
you can tell them they're all wrong or
they're idiots or you could just say
whatever
but if you didn't invest any time and
energy thinking about how to
be effective with your messaging you
might as well just stay home it's not
good enough to be right
you have to be effective and that's
where the effort and energy and and and
navigation of people's
ways of thinking uh how to unravel
habits that are deeply held if those
habits interfere with achieving some
goal so I've never forgotten that and at
every turn where I think you know the
world could be better off if it was a
little more scientifically literate so
that we can become better Shepherds of
this awesome technology
and that we wield
and
people who take it for granted people
who reject it people there's a lot of
sort of misunderstanding of it all
and so again you can't just declare it
and then go home you've got to sort of
fight the good fight and it's not always
a fight it's just is there another way I
can say this where you'll Now understand
what I'm trying to tell you because
previously you didn't is it your fault
or is it my fault that you didn't
understand me I could just declare it to
be your fault and then once again I'm
ineffective so so I tweeted once and it
turned out to be way more controversial
than I think it should have been
the Tweet was
uh how often have we heard a teacher say
these students just don't want to learn
when really that teacher should be
saying maybe I suck at my job
and that's coming from the same place
of if you want to you can't just be
right yeah maybe they don't want to
learn
is it their fault or yours
you're the teacher
why don't you make it interesting for
them yeah that takes extra work you got
to know what's going on what makes the
brain ticks what what what what
receptors exist within them or not
figure that out navigate that yeah then
you'll be
that's then you become a great teacher
we all have great teachers in our lives
all of us
and it's not every one of the teachers
we've had most of them are not that
are not effective and they're not
influential and are not memorable
I've had teachers say how can I become a
better teacher be the teacher that you
remembered having
that one in a hundred teacher be that
teacher
and yeah maybe you'll be effective is it
particularly ironic that a tweet that
you are having this particular idea
about trying to be not just right but
also effective resulted in a tweet about
not being just right but also effective
which was then interpreted in a way
which wasn't effective
well that's why I'm saying it had it had
a little more noise that followed it
than I had intended I thought people say
I never thought about it that way but no
have you ever taught sometimes people
just go on well it is it is the Cesspool
that is social media I get that uh but I
try to always know what the reactions
the range of reactions will be otherwise
I'm I'm miscommunicating at some level
speaking of that you recently had a
conversation with Patrick that David and
there is a clip from that that's done
the rounds a little bit on the internet
I don't know how much attention you pay
to what's going on what's your
postmortem on that situation if you had
one
um well when I'm asked to be on a on you
know on a podcast I I don't it it
usually means people are interested in
what I have to say about the world and
so I'm flattered and I try to be
effective I try to be
um
potent for an audience and not all
audiences are the same the mixtures are
very different and so I try to be aware
of that to the extent that I can in the
time available I was on a four City
tour of Florida
at the time as I give a public talk in
in theaters I was in Orlando and
Jacksonville and and Fort Lauderdale and
uh between two of those cities because
it was driving between among those
cities between two of them is his Studio
and they they mapped this out they knew
this
there's no way I could say no you know
you were driving by here at this time uh
between these two cities I I said well
sure sure and
um he's a big fun you know socially uh
aggressive but not not in it
an angry way but just in a sort of
curious way
so I was I was just fine but Denny he
pivoted and made the whole big part of
the conversation about vaccines
and I was intrigued by that because I'm
an astrophysicist
and but to the extent that I can shed
light on people's confusions
by alerting them of what science is and
how and why it works that I can do
um and speak of the denial that many
people are in on many frontiers of
science that are moving along and it's
curious I'm intrigued by why that
happens
how people might cherry pick certain
information but you know what's behind
it mostly I think
is that I wrote about this and and
recently uh in a whole chapter called
risk and reward where
we are whoa we as a species and there's
plenty of evidence for this are woefully
uh ill-equipped to think statistically
or probabilistically about the world
which is awful at it at every turn
and I don't know in the UK but in the
United States the subject of probability
and statistics is not a fundamental
feature of the math curriculum and then
when you get to high school you're age
16 17 18 it might be elective in some
high schools
but it's otherwise not there
and so and I joked
my one conspiracy theory that I kept
that are we all allowed one conspiracy
theory I have one okay uh the state
lottery
thrives on people betting
they're gonna win
with odds that are dare I say
astronomical against them winning
and you know who doesn't play the
lottery typically are people who deeply
understand probability and statistics
they just don't all right and the
well if they don't
then the state doesn't raise money and
for much many states if not most
the tax revenue from the lottery goes to
fund education
except
it's in their interest to not put
probability and statistics in the
schools okay you think that the part of
the US
justification behind the scenes this
sweaty cabal of
hooded figures
um are purposefully keeping young kids
statistically illiterate so that they
can continue to make money from the
state lottery that if you grant me that
one conspiracy theory yeah that's right
I will permit you to have that one it's
relatively harmless so the you may have
missed this Rishi sunak the new prime
minister of the UK said that children
are going to have to learn maths until
the age of 18 now as opposed to the age
of 16. nice and throw in make those
extra years count and there'll be way
more valuable to learn probability and
statistics than calculus I would say or
even Advanced trigonometry in terms of
just what's relevant to your brain
wiring and decision making that that you
have to go through uh by the way the uh
another story that I tell the American
physical society which is the the United
States
organization of a professional
physicists uh and academic and and
Industrial physicists the American
physical Society they were scheduled to
have their annual meeting in San Diego
and it was a snafu with the hotels and
they had to quickly readjust and re-re
organize and Las Vegas
the MGM Marina now the NDM MGM Grand
rose up and said we'll take you we can
house 4 000 physicists however many
multiple thousands of physicists like on
a dime so they did
so all the physicists went to Las Vegas
and a week later there is a news
headline that said physicists in town
lowest Casino take ever
they've been invited to never come back
ever been Uninvited for any future uh
visits uh the point is it's not that
they somehow knew the odds and and
exploited them it's that they knew that
betting is not really what you should be
doing your money statistically and
probabilistically as a physicist uh I'm
an astrophysicist but the same line of
training I've had some form of
probability in statistics every year of
my life since 10th grade
through graduate school some form
and and so it's just it's not natural to
think so point is the reason why I'm
going here to tell you that
is we embrace
passionate testimony
above data
in almost everything it's why
advertisers will show you this product
worked for me right rather than just
show a bar chart they could just show a
bar chart and say how many it worked for
how many didn't and how well just show
that that would be all the data you need
to decide but no that doesn't work you
have to see another human being
passionately tell you that they use the
product and it works for them
and
that's a feature of the fact that we
don't think statistically and and
advertisers know this and as I've
implied an entire industry exists
because of that weakness and its casinos
well in your books as well you don't
just write a list of compelling stats
right you hang those stats around
narratives those protagonists the
stories there's people stuff happens you
get bought in like we're just not that
compelled some people are for the most
part humans aren't that compelled just
by stats yeah yes and and I accept that
however the narratives that I weave them
into they may be examples of the
statistics that are a little more real a
little more emotional but I'm not
require I'm not EX I'm not trying to
have you believe something that it is
that is not statistically true because I
went to the exception to that statistic
and had that person testify in front of
you
so you heard that somebody died after
they took a vaccine
okay
you know how many people die every
second
who with or without vaccine just there's
a death rate of people in the world and
if everyone is getting vaccinated
somebody's going to die shortly after
they get vaccinated just the statistics
of that but that's not what Rises up
what Rises up is my uncle cousin died
and I heard about some there's a website
that and then all of a sudden the these
cases
become much more real to people than the
statistics of what it is they're trying
to evaluate
and so and I I get it we're human and
and but
all I can do is is offer the truth
the objectively established truth that
is truths established by the methods and
tools of science uh repeated as best as
possible at any given moment where we
know something
that's science is exquisitely tuned to
establish what is objectively true but
better than any other thing I've ever
seen any other system of inquiry when
you think about it it's Why Planes don't
fall out of the sky it's why you know we
can
send a space probe to collide with a
moonlit of an asteroid and time its
difference in its orbit it's how we can
put a park a telescope a million miles
from Earth and observe the early
Universe with it it's how and why that
works
what do you think we do it's why your
smartphone works
how you can find the shortest route to
Grandma's house in this afternoon's
traffic
Not a Human Being is involved in that
decision
it's all technology and science and math
so
maybe just science needs better PR
that's all why do you think it is that
that conversation
generates such
uh virulent response so so passionate
and this is from both sides of the fence
this is from people that are both Pro
and Auntie whatever the strategy is
that's been deployed in your country
have you considered what it is that's
caused people to have that level of uh
vehementness
um
yeah I don't see it as pro and con I see
it as people who are objectively
sharing
truths about the world and those who
reject it so it's not just are you Pro
or are you con with me are you against
me that that would be true in politics
right there's always political
divisiveness if it's purely political
sure I expect that and then a good
healthy democracy that gets debated
daily uh if not then it should be so for
example you don't debate whether or not
humans are warming the Earth
this is an established objective truth
what you do is you so that if you if you
spend time debating that you're you're
wasting taxpayers uh Trust
what you should do is say well I'm
conservative and you you're liberal and
uh my solution is no you you don't tax
uh the solar panels or you do where you
you you you you invest in the in the
industry do you uh put tariffs on
overseas solar panel to build our those
have fascinating
um political solutions that can land
anywhere on the Spectrum depending on
how passionately people argue them how
well they defend them and the like and
so I welcome political conversations to
solve problems in a free democracy
but I will not equate those equations
those sorry I will not equate those
conversations
with conversations where you're sharing
with someone the statistics of Public
Health and then you have people just
choosing to reject them for whatever
reasons they have I think a lot of those
people who are
um
hesitant around the vaccine would be
saying
I have seen other statistics and your
contention would be those statistics are
wrong they're not framed in the right
way I don't think that for the most part
it's right to characterize the people
who are reticent around that stuff as
rejecting stats they've just been
convinced by a different set of
Statistics okay that's the charitable
way to put it I would say that
um there we have agencies
whose sole purpose is to establish
public health
um uh guidance
and if you look carefully if you unpack
what it is they do it's hundreds and in
some cases thousands of health
professionals who are weighing in on
what should be the next steps in the
interest of the health and safety and
security of society
if you now choose a different source
I'm intrigued by that because you don't
choose a different Source when people if
how about the people who say Earth is
flat are you just going to say yeah I
think Earth is flat because they've
convinced me are you going to say no a
plane can't fly so I'm not going to fly
planes are dangerous because I saw one
crash 10 years ago so I'm gonna walk or
I'm gonna take a car
by the way in the United States 40 000
people died in car accidents pedestrians
and drivers and passengers in this past
year that's a that's a higher than in
recent decades so uh the way we choose
our risks
that we would absorb or not is itself
fascinating to me but it shows that
people first so yes if you want it
you're choosing statistics that are not
mainstream I'll just put it that way if
it's not mainstream we we have this
curious
urge
to embrace the claims of someone who
says
you've always thought this was true
but it's not this is true
there's something they want you to
believe this
but this is what's actually true there's
definitely something allitering about
like dating information why that's so
compelling
to people
I think everyone's always done it this
way and they're wrong
and then you listen in they said wow
tell me tell me the right way oh my gosh
they've all been wrong
uh at no time if for those who are
attracted by that kind of scenario are
they saying to themselves
is there a reason why everyone else has
done it this way
that is not being shared with me
that that question doesn't typically get
asked
so in you know I can't
around and keep I mean there's a limit
to this that I can do and
so
I don't know is there a concern there as
well you mentioned before I'm an
astrophysicist and I'm being asked
questions to do with
stuff that is outside of my domain of
competence
is that something that we should be more
concerned about about people kind of
getting out over their skis in other
domains you know we have experts people
that happen to be an expert in one
domain getting asked about the Ukraine
conflict or getting asked about what we
should do about global warming and you
think you you don't have an expertise in
this you just happen to be good in one
area of life and now people seem to
think because you're good in one area
that we should everything that you say
and everything else would it be a better
world if people said
actually I don't know or actually I
don't have a take on that that's not
realistic but and I think your question
conflates two different points so one of
them is people have opinions on things
sure people have opinions on Ukraine and
on Russia and on on global policy yes we
elect officials to represent how we
think our country should be run that's
not a matter of you can only comment
unless you are an expert in
international policy if you're if you
are an expert your comments might be
more convincing because you've thought
about it more deeply but the whole point
of a democracy is on issues where
opinions matter the majority rules
within some framework of a constitution
and morality and the like so that's
different
that's different from someone claiming
they're an expert in something
that does not have to do with opinions
and they're not
so in from in my case
I do not accept invitations to be on
shows
where the main point is for me to
comment on a subject outside of my
expertise
if they said we need you on a global
warming show get a climate scientist we
need you on a vax show get a get a
medical professional I decline those
interviews you would never know it
because in larger interviews that I'm on
when the interviewer pivots to other
topics such as we have kind of done here
um that typically gets excerpted for
YouTube and it looks like I'm commenting
on all of these things all the time so
it really just reflects people's uh
interest and I respect that the
difference is
I'm sharing with you mainstream
uh content
it's mainstream
in all cases
all right so it is the emergent
consensus of professionals that I have
read and I've understand I might be able
to explain it in another way then others
couldn't because I'd spent a lot of time
in that space
um but that's what I'm doing
so for people to say uh you're wrong
about the vaccines I'm going to debate
it's not about me it's about what
medical professionals are sharing that I
am sharing with you okay it's got
nothing to do with me
now if uh the difference would be if you
said
um which vaccine do you advise or how do
you no I would never do such a thing
okay
um
do you do you devise against taking a
vaccine all I can tell you are these
numbers that I get from the CDC and
other medical professionals and other
public health professionals that's what
I get and that's what I'm sharing with
you but the fact that people come to me
and want to attack me for saying that
I'm intrigued by this
because they think I'm somehow have some
some separately researched agenda
about the topic that is not the case
and so but it's true for all of it
all of it now I have stronger opinions
where it involves people who are sure
they're abducted by UFOs I can have that
conversation because that's closer to my
expertise and I can offer opinions about
that that may be of interest to you and
they are deeply informed opinions why do
you think some people so otherwise
I want to know why you think when people
believe that they've been abducted by
UFOs what do you think is going on I I I
my point is not whether or not they've
been abducted but
they're eyewitness testimony
in the court of Sciences insufficient to
uh convince an authentic skeptic on it
we just need better data than your
eyewitness testimony I know in the court
of law I need a witness you know in the
court of science that is the last thing
anyone will say I need a witness no I
need a chart recorder I need the the the
the the the you know I need some other
evidence that wasn't processed by your
brain and we know this so that's why I
just need better evidence and what has
been put forth doesn't satisfy that so
if you've been abducted
here's what next time you're abducted
just snatched something off the shelf an
ashtray or whatever I don't do alien
smoke I don't know it's not you know
some
device and bring and you have something
and take that to the that'd be cool oh
yeah then we can have that conversation
but until then I I don't have it it's it
doesn't convince me enough to to pursue
it
so I don't stop people from doing it you
want to bag yourself an alien with a net
go right ahead I will not stop you and
you'll be the most famous person ever in
the world if you capture one
and by the way the the janitor that
works at Area 51
all the janitor has to do is take a
snapshot of the aliens stockpile there
that General will lose its the job
overnight and they'll be the most famous
richest janitor there ever was you could
live stream it okay we have methods for
that today
so
you spoke about uh risk and reward as
two of the things in your new book you
also talk about life and death and given
that the universe is at least part of
your domain of competence
is it
more terrifying or liberating to realize
that the universe is pretty much
indifferent to
us as individuals life on planet Earth
what we do are motivations and the way
that our lives continue forward
yeah it depends on the individual
because that's an emotional reaction to
an objective fact so it is true the
universe could care less what's
happening to you in spite of all of our
urges to the contrary
going far back even pre-religion okay
religion kind of codifies that you mean
something to the universe and the gods
that matter to it but even before then
there was or or there was the sky
knows about about you right this is the
the seeds of astrology
it's right I'm born at this time and and
Mars and Venus and the sun they know
about me and they and they and they have
information about my life
this urge that the universe
as vast as it is somehow knows who you
are
and how you're living who are you going
to sleep with and what your chances of
earning money will be these are early
signs of that need
it's a need
and it takes
a lot of sort of brain
uh I don't know what you call it
adjustments to recognize that it is we
alone
who can or will save us from ourselves
here on Earth and all the challenges and
problems that we face that is
enlightening
to some it's terrifying but I'm saying
no it's it restores control
Over Our Fate to ourselves
so now we have to become better
Shepherds of who and what we are and of
the world that we that sustains Us in
order to have any hope of the future
that we
uh wish for
for civilization on Earth do you think
that we are the only corner of the
universe that's got Consciousness in it
so as best as I have
as best as I can judge
um
Consciousness remains poorly understood
as a thing and how do I know that
because every year somebody writes a
book on it
the more books that are actively written
on a subject the more evidence that is
that we don't understand it
because otherwise you wouldn't have to
keep writing books on it it would be
done
all right ask yourself how many books
are there on Newtonian gravity there's
like two books and they're on the shelf
and they've been there for 200 years all
right and so then people aren't still
writing about this subject so that tells
me we have way farther to go before we
have any deep understanding of
Consciousness we're not we're not in a
good place to judge
what other animals also have
consciousness
all right the the religious arguments
would say we're the only one and then
other arguments are saying well quote to
hire animals which is itself a bias
towards who and what we are relative to
other animals you know are bacteria
conscious well they're really in control
of your body in your digestive tract
they're more bacteria that live and work
within one centimeter of your lower
colon than the total number of humans
who have ever been born
so however high up you want to think of
yourself to the bacteria you are a
darkened
vessel of fecal matter of anaerobic
fecal matter
and if you upset them they're in charge
of your life because you tell you
they'll you'll know exactly where the
toilet is and how many Paces away if you
upset them so they'll be say the higher
animals I'm not even I'm not engaging
that level of ranking I will say it'll
be hard to not imagine that
other animals or other mammals are also
have a Consciousness certainly your cat
your dog no one will deny them this
horses or people who ride horses
um all the animals for which we have
somebody who claims to be a Whisperer to
them The Horse Whisperer the Cat
Whisperer the dog the rabbit whisper
whatever I would think those animals
would have what we think of as
Consciousness and so Consciousness is
not rare on Earth Earth is not Rare
Earth has a the fact that we're on a
planet around a star
um in a Goldilocks zone where the
temperature is just right the planet
catalogs are growing exponentially
uh 27 years ago we knew of no exoplanets
um planets orbiting other stars now the
catalog is rising through five thousand
and so these are places we might look
for life and we've only just begun that
search so no I'm not saying we're the
only corner of the Galaxy with
Consciousness there's no reason to think
that and there's every reason to think
the opposite especially given that we're
made of the most common ingredients in
the universe
hydrogen carbon oxygen nitrogen
the most abundant ingredients in the
universe and light happen to be
opportunistic
taking what it was given and turning it
into life when it had a source of heat a
heat energy such as what we got from the
Sun so now
and we're looking
I learned only a couple of weeks ago
that Proxima Centauri and the exoplanet
that seems to be in that system is
similar sort of size to Earth similar
sort of distance from a star which is
putting out similar sorts of amounts of
energy and it seems to be Rocky as well
like how ridiculously unlikely is it
that within the the closest other system
to us
happens to have a planet that
looks good in terms of options for
habitability
well there's a there's a branch of
probability called Bayesian statistics
where you you take a prior
and you say so you don't calculate the
statistics from scratch you say I
already have some information
does shouldn't that allow me to do the
statistics standing in a different place
than assuming nothing and so the
Bayesian statistics is of the hundreds
of billions of stars in the galaxy
if the nearest star system has a planet
just like Earth
probably earth-like planets are common
if the nearest one has it uh yes folding
in the likelihood of us now being two
for two in terms of us going out yeah
yes or if we find Life on Mars not on
the surface unlikely but beneath the
surface where there's we still think
there's water present that was once on
the surface and became a kind of
permafrost Mars is very cold and
inhospitable in many places on its
surface but there might be forms of life
where it's actually rather hospitable
right I mean with you would die pretty
quickly on the North Pole
um
but polar bears just hang out there
right so that they doing the backstroke
okay and they're mammals by the way so
so what we think of as hospitable could
be different
among life forms on Earth especially
from different life forms from planet to
planet point is if in the nearest star
system we find a planet that looks like
Earth is Rocky like Earth is in the
Goldilocks zone like Earth
it allows you to think
that earth-like planets may be much more
common than we had ever imagined and if
we find life in our backyard
then
we're we're again saying starting there
we say oh my gosh our backyard the
nearest plant planets to us the moons of
Jupiter it's right there oh my gosh
that it allows you to think maybe life
is even more common than the most
generous estimates we've ever given
that would be terrifying are you
familiar I'm gonna guess that you will
be with the great filter hypothesis
wait what would be terrifying if we
found microbe
organisms on the surface of Mars or
underneath the surface of Mars why is
that terrifying it's just nature because
of the great filter which is my sort of
most recent Obsession from Robin Hansen
so he says why is it that we can't see
all of the aliens one of the potentials
that gets put forward is there is a
particular line in the sand that
civilizations tend to not get past if
you take that that might be one of the
reasons that we haven't seen any other
what seemed to be intelligent life forms
out there in the universe
if we find life that is near to us that
is behind our level of development what
that suggests is that this great filter
still lies ahead which means that we are
yet to get past it
sure I don't have a problem with that
that started uh a few decades ago when
it was suggested the variance on this
this great filter but it's very it
invokes
um fundamental but still very human
philosophies on the existence of such a
filter so it would be well this is a
variant on it but I think it's it's a
it's a little more
present so it's
uh you want to go colonize planets okay
so you go out and do that
well I want to do that too well I can't
colonize your planet because you you so
I gotta find a different planet so if
you breed a civilization
that is into
colonizing planets and taking ownership
of them
then
everyone goes out to colonize planets
there will be a point
where there aren't enough planets to be
colonized and now people want to
colonize each other's planets
creating a level of conflict a kind of
implosion of this exploration paradigm
and that that implosion basically
dismantles the entire exercise of what
it is to colonize planets
and that is a planetary a direct
planetary analog
to European colonization of the world up
to and including the Second World War
all right uh there is England uh British
Empire the Sun never sets on the British
Empire by the way that sentence is
identically equivalent to the Sun never
Rises on the British Empire if it never
sets it also never Rises okay just let's
be logically consistent about that but
um there's England there's Portugal
there's Spain there's France and and the
Netherlands and and everybody's and then
at some point
you all ended up fighting each other
yes you're fighting each other for
control of New York that's the Dutch and
the and the British and the fra and
everybody's fighting and and it's all
gone practically now okay and because
there's nothing left to fight over
there's no major colonization efforts
such as what occurred in the in in
1600s 17 and 1800s so it's that it's
that analog extended to space and that's
an interesting analog what it says is
the urge to explore in this way is
incompatible
with being successful
expressing your urge to explore
and and another line that could be
joined you can think of many of these
that the Technologies are so awesome and
so powerful that the civilization
implodes within it
they destroy their environment they blow
themselves up they this is a big concern
of course during the Cold War and
persists as a concern in modern
landscape of geopolitics so it could be
that a civilization becomes so Advanced
it has the power to render itself
extinct
and that could be another Great Divide
okay so uh yeah we can come up with all
kinds of reasons there I don't know if
it's obvious to people that this
question was first posed by
um Enrico Fermi it was called the Fermi
Paradox and it's not just where are they
all right there's more thought that went
into it than just where are they
it's because we know how old the
universe is
and we know how long it would take to
colonize a Galaxy
so let's assume you don't have warp
drives but you do manage to go let's say
10 the speed of light all right is that
too much to ask ten percent give us 10
the speed of light all right so if you
can do that uh uh the office Century
system is four light years away so 10 of
that that would take you 40 years to get
there all right now it's a one-way trip
as the European
um explorers and Colonists came to the
new world those were one-way trips for
them all right so that we understand a
one-way trip so they go there and then
they pitch tent and then they develop
space exploration and they move on to
another play but they move on to two
planets instead of just one and they
colonize and they go to four and then
they go to eight and then 16. and it's
50 years in between each one if you add
up the time and at the rate at which
this spreads this is what Enrico Fermi
did and as we call a back of the
envelope calculation here's something
you do while you're sitting there
doesn't involve a computer you realize
that you can completely populate all
planets in the galaxy in just a few
million years
a few million years
10 million years tops
Earth has been around for four and a
half billion
billion years
10 million is a
small fraction of four and a half
billion so if there are other planets
that were formed before Earth was a
billion years before Earth two billion
years three billion years we formed
seven eight billion years after the
universe formed all kinds of stuff could
have been happening in the universe
before we got here
so the question where are they is
legitimate in the sense that
anyone who was going to colonize would
have colonized at all
that leads to the interesting question
maybe maybe we are a colonial Outpost
and don't know it okay
I mean so fun it's great food for
science fiction storytelling but I don't
I don't see anything terrifying about it
I don't you can't invest in Motion in
Cosmic discovery
you can invest in Motion in wow I'm
learning something new today not oh my
gosh what does this mean am I no just
just
celebrate it do you think that we're
going to have problems when it comes to
astropolitics from Earth yes yes yes
we'll start with the the the the the
outer space treaty okay well it's a much
longer title and I always forget the
full title the treaty on the peaceful
uses of outer space among it's a big
title right it came out of the U.N back
in 1967 something like that if you re
and that was a very turbulent time we
were in a hot War the United States was
in a hot war in Vietnam and a cold war
with the Soviet Union and NATO and and
we had a civil rights movement campus
unrest it was a turbulent time and so if
you read it it's it's very Kumbaya it's
like in space if it'll only be peace in
space and if you're in trouble and
you're in another country I will help
you in space and you read it it's like
oh it's so beautiful it's so un okay
United Nations is everything you'd want
the United Nations to be and represent
and and I I was taken by it initially
until I just got older and I got I don't
know it's not so much cynical I just
became a realist and I said
really
really what you're saying is
if everybody goes into space
then we'll stop killing one another
but on Earth you can't stop them from
killing one another
but somehow space is going to be
different
so my my interpretation is
show me you can stop killing each other
on Earth
then I'll believe you can make this work
in space
and you haven't shown that to me yet so
I'm skeptical
one of the things that I realized when
there was a passing asteroid that there
was a potential project to go and maybe
try and Chip a little bit off bring it
back to Earth it was going to have I
don't know what it was lithium or gold
or something is going to have some
valuable
Repository
if you did that it would completely
wreck the market for that on Earth
because the entire economic system the
way that the earth works it's a closed
system right we know how much difficulty
there is in associated with doing this
particular thing and it's within a set
amount that the Earth has it's a
restricted Supply kind of like Bitcoin I
suppose yeah but it's uh it wouldn't
wreck it it would change it yes okay I
mean you value judging and saying that
would be bad no
just let's talk about the consequences
of it uh Nature has a way of pre-sifting
ingredients on the periodic table of
elements so that when it makes new
planets uh it's hot and molten and the
heavy Things fall to the middle and the
light things float to the top
when we think of rocks we think of them
as heavy
but Earth's crust is made of Rock
the rock is the lightest thing on earth
and that's why it floated to the top
what's our core made out of it's made
out of iron and nickel and you know
cadmium and all these heavy metals went
to the Center of the Earth there's some
veins that got trapped while that we now
call them oars that got trapped while
the Earth was Cooling and so they're the
gold oars and you know yes
if that weren't the case we wouldn't we
would have no access to any of those
well in a protoplanet that started doing
this
slam it with another protoplanet and
these pieces break off you have entire
asteroids made of Rock
those are from the outer shells of these
protoplanets and entire asteroids made
of heavy ingredients such as metals and
those are asteroids made from the middle
of fewer of those but they're out there
and we know where they are and they have
the greatest concentration of metals and
Rare Earth elements and all these things
that are otherwise rare or hard to get
to on Earth there they are right there
yes if you last sued one of these
asteroids and brought it back to Earth
the marketplace in every one of the
metals in that would be completely
transformed
and yeah gold would be you know it's a
ten dollars an ounce or something it
would be really cheap or less
they're asteroids with more gold on it
than has ever been mined in the his mind
or extracted in the history of the world
on the single asteroid
so gold by the way is highly
technologically useful
highly it's the most malleable substance
so you can take a little bit and flatten
it out and make sheets you can do and so
people's inventiveness
which previously was constrained because
of how expensive it was if gold is ten
dollars an ounce instead of 800 an ounce
you could think of other things to do
with it opening up whole new
marketplaces
just think about that look how cheap
computers are
yeah you got to drop a thousand dollars
but for what that thing does
oh my gosh you wouldn't need a city box
worth of computers
40 years 50 years ago to do that and now
it's sitting on your hip
when the price of computing dropped we
found more and more things to do with it
do people worry about the collapse of
the computer industry no
they found other things to do undreamed
of by that earlier generation
among them is let's build a computer
that fits in your shirt pocket that
talks to orbiting satellites put up
there by the U.S military to find
coordinates on Earth so that you can get
the quickest distance to Grandma's house
in this afternoon's traffic
oh my gosh did anyone imagine that no
it's another application for something
that is cheap
cheap
it's so cheap you can't even charge for
it practically
I I'm I'm old enough just to sound like
Father time here
um when there's one computer on the
campus on the University campus and you
had an account and you would you would
write your software and you'd run it
through the computer and you get the
results they would charge you you'd get
a bill for it running and it would be
like oh my gosh I need a grant to pay
for the bill to run my computer on this
one Mainframe in the center of Campus
foreign
try to keep your emotion out of the
consequences of things they aren't just
what they are
I don't know I don't want to tell you
what to do with your emotions but keep
in mind that often the emotions aren't
because things will change from what
you're accustomed to
but that's not always bad
speaking of things that might be bad I
read a book called seven Eves by Neil
Stevenson and the first line of that
book The Moon explodes
how much Havoc would be caused on Earth
if the moon went away if I could just
snap my fingers and the moon left
well astrophysicist with delight in this
because the moon wreaks havoc on the
trans on the on the visibility of dim
objects in the night sky especially the
phase of the moon as it's closest to
Full Moon
you know the full moon is like six times
brighter than the half moon the the laws
of Optics make the full moon much
brighter than just the simple geometry
of two halves so it's a fascinating fact
so that complete so we have what's
called Dark time and and light time and
and if you want to see something really
deep in the universe you have to apply
for the coveted dark time when the moon
is not up so we would be happy first of
all second uh the tides would drop in
intensity to about a third of what they
are and we would just have solar Tides
instead of lunar tides
and uh what else would we have
um
the uh you wouldn't have it evenings
wouldn't be as romantic
okay uh Islam would not have this symbol
the Crescent Moon and a star in the sky
uh the lunar calendar would have never
have been invented or to be orphaned in
place once you snap the moon out of
existence so people would have to switch
over probably to the Gregorian calendar
which is not Moon based it's based on
Earth seasons does the man does the moon
not do something stabilize the rotation
of the Earth
as well so yes so oh you're talking
about historically so the moon
um has so Earth's of the tip of her
thanks for mentioning that I almost
forgot the tip of Earth's we're tipped
on our Axis
Three Degrees 23 and a half somewhere
around there close enough and
um that and we process on our axis like
a top whoever spins tops anymore I don't
know you spin it and the top starts to
wobble while it's spinning it's wobbling
we're wobbling in space so that's that's
procession okay that period is 26 000
years all right so we've seen this in in
recorded history
um and we've measured it another thing
it does it Bobs up and down
so while it's processing while we are
spinning
and the bobbing up and down is a change
in the angle
of our tip relative to the Sun
and the gravity of the moon has a way of
stabilizing that because that would tip
much more um wildly than it currently
does
I forgot the numbers right now just
several degrees each way but without the
Moon it would be much larger than that
and that would make for much more severe
seasonal temperature changes
and yeah so civilization would have
developed differently from how it has
in under that influence I remember I
read an article from someone who was
trying to do an astrophysics analysis of
why the seasons in Game of Thrones could
be so difficult yeah I remember that
yeah the Winter's coming Winter's coming
to stay there for three years Winter's
coming
so you can ask in fact on one of my
podcasts uh I I think we addressed this
I I interviewed uh George R Martin for
one of on my Star Talk podcast but I
don't think that was the podcast where
we talked about what planet this could
be so what you do is you you back you
you you you back into the story right so
you say all right how long does
uh how long does it take to get to
Winter
how long how many months or years is
there not winter and then you you
configure a a planet Moon star system
that is on an orbit there are other
consequences because if the orbit it
gets close and far then the size of the
star in the sky has to get bigger and
smaller I don't remember them
referencing the size of their Sun so
yeah it's fun uh what we call not so
much revisionist but um
it's the the whole field of apologetics
where you have something that is taken
to be true and you do whatever you can
to justify how and why that's the case
it's apologetics from the original is it
Latin meaning defender of their
religious apologetics for example who
defend their version of the Bible
against people who say it's not true so
it's a fun exercise in the Sci-Fi World
they do that for for Star Wars
um
uh Han Solo said he he did the Kessel
Run in 12 parsecs
the boasting about the speed of a ship
and that's just wrong okay what does he
mean you can't give a Time measure with
a with a measure of length a parsec is a
measure of length all right 12 parsecs
is about 40 light years and no that's
like saying oh uh how tall how tall are
you
um
how tall are you I am
what's an example
uh how tall are you I am 55 miles per
hour
okay this is okay how long did it take
you to go 12 parsec this is not
just no this works the units matter okay
um what's your body temperature oh it's
it's 43 cents you know no it's not
all right it's like whoever was in The
Writing Room
people who took a sentence and worked
hard to find a way to make that rather
than say yeah he [__] up rather than
say that uh not he but the writers right
they they came up with some back Doorway
to account for it it's like okay that's
how you want to do it
I'll walk away now have you read about
this habitable habitable worlds
Observatory
which has been proposed
uh there's something called a wasp
collaboration which is a wide area
s wide area search for planets which is
ground-based it's got dozens of
countries participating sharing their
data and they're finding planets
um I think they're targeting earth-like
planets I don't know if that's the same
thing but I know so I I read an article
about it in sessions of the recent 241st
meeting of the American Astronomical
Society Nasser officials outlined their
approach to developing what the agency
now calls the habitable worlds
Observatory a 6.5 meter Space Telescope
operating at ultraviolet visit oh no
it's a whole other thing oh oh my gosh
yes oh that would have just happened
literally because this week American
astronomical says those are my people
and we I wasn't there for that meeting
otherwise I could give you firsthand uh
retelling of this rather than the the
journalist account but we just we meet
um our biggest meeting is once a year in
January uh oh that's great I'm glad to
hear that uh what is it the budget
projection uh for it the it's
2035 to 2014 45 and you would need to
increase NASA's astrophysics budget
currently about 1.5 billion a year to
2.5 billion annually later in the 2020.
you don't have enough money and if you
don't get of money it's going to take
ages and people were mad that it was
going to take ages basically what
um first we are forward thinkers in my
field the James Webb Space Telescope was
on paper in proposals decades ago
for what it would be and what it would
do
and you spec it as best you can at the
time but technology changes and and so
we learn things in science certain
things may be impossible some things are
easier than we thought so that you can
make adjustments along the way but the
James Webb was on paper decades ago as
was the Hubble telescope on paper
decades before it was launched and so
um so yeah we are very forward thinkers
and the way you do it is you increment
the budget and that money goes too you
don't spend it all at once because you
don't have it and you couldn't spend it
because often it involves technology
developments so yeah I mean search for
planets is a big industry now as you'd
expect because we're looking for life
that must be infuriating to do a project
which is going to take so long that you
know that the technology that you are
going to design it with will be way
obsolete by the time that it comes to
launch it
yeah so you do your best to forward
project that based on how quickly things
went obsolete before
so with Hubble
because it was a serviceable telescope
they were able to swap out the was it
Microsoft uh
XP or something one of the early
operating systems and the chip was a 286
chip you know it was uh once you know
plus Hubble was delayed in its launch
because of the Challenger disaster
and that delay meant it was sitting
there
in mothballs not literally multiples we
were sitting there
getting old as technology and Computing
Advanced and bandwidths and
communication protocols and the like
so when it launched it was already old
in the first servicing Mission which had
to fix the optical problem they were
able to swap out a whole bunch of things
and bring it up to date
so yeah so yeah it's a it's a challenge
the one rule in astronomical research or
any scientific research is you want the
experiment to be done before you die
okay right so the person that's
designing it might put a mortal limit on
what's going to go on and the budget
appropriately correct that's right I
like the Mortal limit I like that that's
what we would call it
what are the mortality factors of this
project right well Louie's gonna die and
then Susie's gonna die and yeah so you
give them other projects that can happen
within their lifetime quicker right okay
you can go and get us a coffee or
something that would be capable what are
you working on next what can people
expect from you this year
oh my gosh yeah I'm I have I have a book
the third book of my uh
in the spirit of my podcast coming at
Stark talk uh it's a third book it's
called to infinity and beyond well it's
not coming out until like December so no
I don't need to distract people with it
but it's just it's a celebration of
cosmic discovery
but through the through the the start
talking and lens which is pop culture
and humor and but you learn the fits and
starts of Science and how we went from A
to B to C to beyond the alphabet where
there are no letters to ascribe uh off
to Infinity so it's it's a it's a
close-up look at how we make discoveries
and how we celebrate them and how we
lament the ones that fail
so it's a candid look at how science
works that's cool that's that's in the
fall so but we're still editing that and
that's that's still happening otherwise
I just want to go to the Bahamas because
I had a very uh very full year uh with
the publication of of the book and oh by
the way we were talking about uh the
moon if the moon weren't there there's a
whole chapter on just called Earth and
Moon and just if you want to sit down
and bask in what the moon is to us and
I'm glad we have a moon because I'll
repeat the off-quoted
um uh what do you call it it's not an
episode The off quoted
um saying in the SP in the space faring
industry said if God wanted us to
explore space
he would have given us a moon
it sounds a little backwards but
yeah we have a moon and we've explored
space if think about it if we didn't
have a moon
to draw us
as a as a destination
would we have had a space program I mean
I I wonder this that's a really
interesting question because the barrier
to entry for space travel would be so
high if the closest thing that we were
going to was Mars correct correct we
still haven't done Venus was closer but
we'd learned before then I'd hope that
we would vaporize upon learning so yes
Mars for sure yeah wow yeah that is very
interesting uh and Starry Messenger also
relatively new out now people can go
yeah yeah in fact it's uh in the United
States it's at least
for this last I checked it's still on
the best seller list but it will surely
get bumped because it was hanging on at
the bottom it'll get bumped by your your
boy
um Prince Prince Harry well I mean if
you if if you want to compete with
Prince Harry you're going to have to
spend half a chapter talking about your
penis
it's a a step I don't know whether
you've descended into that realm yet
with your writing but I know I I I I I
you know the people were joking where he
says he wants to go into private life
and not be disturbed
um but to make sure that happens he goes
on Oprah and then goes on 60 minutes and
then publishes a book and then this and
now he can have his peace and quiet
right so anyway I'll make room I have no
hesitation making room for ex royalty uh
that's how the the book lists work but I
was delighted to be on the best sellers
at all with a science book I mean it's
it's not often that that happens so
congratulations
United States it had some following yeah
look Neil I appreciate you I appreciate
your time and uh I'll see you next time
thank you excellent thanks for having me
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]